you've actually you mentioning before
you've charged people under Espionage
you've got experience in law enforcement
yes what do you think about so there's a
bunch of different charges and there's
New York there's there's Florida Federal
Jersey I can run through them real quick
yeah tell me what you so so first you
gotta died out of New York for you know
the falsifying business record stuff
right which that typically is a BS
misdemeanor but they're trying to get
them on the felony version of it which
whatever Alvin Bragg has a hard on
against Trump I think you campaign if
I'm not mistaken is D.A saying I'm gonna
go after Trump right then you got the
classified documents case out of
Mar-A-Lago which you know the FBI if you
guys know they did the search warrant at
the place Etc he didn't return some
records They searched the place found a
bunch of documents and they went ahead
and charged them with that right and
then now you got the DC stuff with the
January 6 which they're saying that he
used his political power to try to stop
the election and you know
Etc and then Georgia pretty much hit him
with the same exact situation but uh
with Georgia statutes and they did it
under the racketeering Act of Georgia
right it's a state case so he has two
State cases one in New York one in
Georgia and then two Federal ones one
out of the southern district of Florida
um and then another one out of um uh the
the um the District of Columbia out of
DC so that's the overall cases but sorry
you got something no yeah but that's
that's the general overall the general
question of what what do you think about
the charges in your experience okay you
said they were trumped up yeah like the
Georgia ones I think are uh what
concerns me
um is the uh the classified documents
case and and the reason why because I
actually did a case
on this uh I think it's 18 USC 793 e
someone could check that if they want on
the on the law right say one more time
18 USC 793 E I believe is a statute
um which is gathering transmitting or
losing defense information bam there you
go so that's what they're getting Trump
that's what they're going after him for
right and that's one of the statutes and
uh that's if those are the same charges
that Robert Hanson they famous went
after him for the corrupt FBI agent that
sold secrets to the Russians back uh you
know about 20 years ago now he actually
just died in prison a couple months ago
but my thing is with the Espionage Act
it's fairly clear-cut hey this is
National Defense information and or it's
classified you have it you're not
supposed to have it uh and the thing
that worries me is that the prosecution
have him on recording saying well you
know when he was I think he was he was
doing an interview over a book or
something like that but they have them
on on they have it in the discovery hey
you know I you know when I was President
I could have Declassified this this is
you know secret stuff it doesn't improve
the documents that that doesn't that is
not evidence he had classified documents
well they have the witness saying that
they saw the documents they know what
the documents are so what has actually
said that he I didn't know that I know
that they they claim that he they had
the um superseding indictment that got
him on the Iran documents and they said
that he had classify documents yeah but
I don't I don't think the audio proves
that the audio who knows what he was
talking about well what the audience the
witness says what the audio proves is is
this because one of his biggest defenses
was and I just want to put this out
there I like Trump I'm going to vote for
Trump I'm putting that out there um you
can say that I'm biased towards Trump
but I have to acknowledge that like with
these statutes Etc that this is not good
that he had because it's pretty
clear-cut and the thing is that he said
oh well I could have Declassified them
that's the my authority as the president
he's correct but he's admitting on the
the record that he did not declassify
them and he's acknowledging that their
National Defense and or classified
information to a degree so and here's
the other thing the two with National
Defense information ndi it doesn't
necessarily have to be classified to be
constituted as ndi it can be anything
that's military and you're not supposed
to have that right or certain people
aren't supposed to have access to that
so that's what concerns me because they
they found it there at Mar-A-Lago and
here's the other thing too they're going
to argue oh well we gave you the
opportunity to give some of the
documents back which he actually did he
did give some of the documents back and
then charging for those documents but
the problem is that he lied to his
lawyers right and he said oh yeah no we
gave all the documents back Etc and then
his assistant the guy that they indicted
um while to Noah is how it's pronounced
if I'm not mistaken he him and another
guy moved the boxes around right and
then Trump's lawyers certified that they
gave everything over to the FBI then
here's what really scares me I read
through the indictment and in the
indictment it says that they have
lawyers notes well that's not good
because we know that lawyers right all
the correspondents with their defendants
is considered privilege law enforcement
not supposed to have that so for example
when I was doing interviews if a guy I
was interviewing said I want a lawyer
and the lawyer shows up and they talk I
have to leave the room and anything I
hear can't be used is privilege 100 he
could say I did it I can't use that
right so the fact that the FBI put
privileged information in the indictment
tells me that those lawyers flipped so
those lawyers are not cooperating with
the beer doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if they flip uh if no they're
going to testify against Trump is my
point I don't think they'll be allowed
to no absolutely will and I'll tell you
why I'll tell you why the reason why is
because the FBI probably told them oh
you guys came here certified this
document said you to give us all the
boxes right
and there now it looks like they lie to
them and they're complicit in the crime
your lawyer cannot be compelled to
testify against you I'm pretty sure they
cannot do that I'm not saying they won't
because a lot of things they can't do
they're doing anyway they're currently
charging lawyers but I'll make I'll make
two counterpoints go ahead please the
first is
I'm not a lawyer man I could be totally
wrong I just Google search can your lord
testify against you and the first thing
that pops up is your attorney cannot be
compelled to testify against you or
disclose what you said during your
conversations so if they were to give
privileged Communications it doesn't
matter they did it's in the indictment
right and so that's gonna that's gonna
be a supreme court challenge that
Trump's going to win on the other thing
I'll add is the law you cited not saying
that this in any way shuts down the case
against Trump because this is just
something that you're familiar with I
don't know exactly what they're going to
jump with but this one says Trump had to
believe it would advantage or a foreign
Nation or injury the United States I I
don't think you can prove that with what
Trump did if Trump sold information or
flew on a trip to Russia with the
information he's indeed he's in deep
trouble he's got boxes in his house
you're going to claim that Trump thought
that would injure the United States he's
like there's a news report about it in
Politico the the documents he's talking
about and he wasn't providing any
information or advantage to a foreign
Nation well but again if they're getting
Trump on a different charge this one
just specifically says uh some sections
of it there's different subsections but
but they all say something to the effect
of aforementioned right so I'm there
there are uh yeah there's a million
subsections in that law it's written
very broadly for a reason so but what
I'm saying is that that's the general
statute that they hit him with right
it's 18 USC 793. there's different
sections section e that you mentioned
says in which the information the
professor possessor has has reason to
believe could be used to the injury of
the United States or to the advantage of
a foreign Nation willfully communicates
delivers transmits or causes to be
communicated delivery transmit attempts
to communicate Deliverance oh my geez
these laws
the same and fails to deliver to the
office employee of the United States
entitled to receive it blah blah I I
think a component of this could be wrong
is he he had to have believed that
having those documents would cause harm
to the United States
well that's kind of that's applied by
that's kind of implied by the by the
level of classification of the documents
it's put in there everybody knows when
you have a clearance if certain
documents were to get out right whether
it's secret top secret confidential
whatever it is they say okay this
document if got out it would be would
great cause grave danger United States
or would cause severe danger United
States that you know this when you do
when you get your clearance when you
have certain documents it's put all the
documents are labeled so it's kind of
implied when you have a clearance when
you're dealing with that type of
document that hey if this were to get
out would be an issue so they know it
and again this is this is coming from a
guy that likes Trump but my concern is
Jack Smith would not have indicted him
on this if they were not 100 sure that
they would be able to get them and the
thing that kills it is that his lawyers
certified to the FBI yo we gave
everything back and then they went and
did the search warrant and then they
found the documents there so that puts
the lawyers in a precarious situation
where the FBI can now go to them and say
we're gonna die you guys too because how
do we know that you guys weren't
complicit in it well no we're not
listening we'll cooperate and then they
gave them memorialized notes and it's in
the indictment so my thing is this
whether they decide to testify or not is
one thing but they're absolutely
cooperating I know that they would not
put privileged information like that in
in the Federal indictment if they were
not cooperating they have a bunch of
witnesses and then you guys
lawyers too like I thought I saw the
other day that you just changed lawyers
anyways yeah yeah we had this
conversation the other day with Eric
Hundley and I said that I I think
they're going to
with uh Chase burrow who's being
criminally charged his trial is going to
be October 23rd I said what are the
chances
he takes a deal or gets convicted for
you know Espionage Act Insurrection Rico
blah blah whatever they're charging with
and in that trial
he makes statements of fact and provides
some kind of testimony Court heard
evidence that Trump instructed him to do
it
the Democrats then file a civil charge
under the 14th Amendment to remove Trump
from the election because of the insert
because he's an insurrectionist they say
we got a guy who's convicted who told
the courts under oath these things
implicating Donald Trump in an act of
insurrection now we've we we use this
evidence to have him removed from the
ballot he said well but they couldn't do
that because Trump's not been convicted
and I'm like I'm not talking about
jumping convicted of a crime I'm saying
a civil lawsuit under the 14th of his
name taken off the ballot
his argument was they they can't do that
and my response is just bro there's a
lot of things they can't do they can't
arrest someone's legal counsel and they
did
like Jenna Ellis is the biggest red flag
because she's just like she was just
Trump's lawyer she's not like she she's
not going around knocking on doors
demanding people chains votes or
anything like that she's just Trump's
lawyer and they criminally charge her
under Rico and that's why I'm saying the
the Georgia the Georgia stuff I'm not
too concerned with I think if anything
it's gonna it's gonna get watered down
Fanny Willis is a cloud chaser trying to
move up in the political world I get
that but I'm saying they're all going to
do whatever they can legal or not so
everything you're saying about is
lawyers I'm saying well maybe they can't
do that they're gonna and that's why
politically the left does so much better
right because they just ignore the rules
all the time anyway they do the
Republicans are for the most part like
we always say just Democrats going the
speed limit because the Democrats know
that power is gained not by following
the rules but by breaking them and they
don't have a problem with that because
most of the people have been poisoned by
the media anyways like I have friends on
both sides as people on both sides
posting the mug shot and the people who
don't like women are posting it they
can't even really articulate why yeah or
explain why these charges in particular
are so egregious they just know they
don't like them and so you take a
general public that's been poisoned
against someone by the media and you
take politicians and activist DA's who
have no problem wielding political and
legal power against someone even if it's
against the law you know if it doesn't
follow the letter of the law and you get
to a place like this and then somebody
asks how did our country get here well
that's how it got here yeah and like I
said the Georgia stuff I'm not too too
worried about the classified documents
has me concerned right as a trump
supporter so because because I know how
that statue it's very I mean you read it
it's extremely it's broadly written geez
and it's and it's designed to go after
people for Espionage so they're going to
do everything in their power to get you
in every nook and cranny and yeah dude
it's and then the fact that the lawyers
are probably going to cooperate we know
that they're going to try to flip the
guy that tried to destroy the
surveillance footage they're gonna try
to flip his assistant natsua they're
gonna and it is what it is man I mean
the only way I see him beating this is
my my situation my what I think is he
would have to become president and
pardon himself but it's not explicitly
written in the Constitution if a
president can pardon himself it's just
that he can pour it in so for the
federal charges if not for the state
stuff I know me and you had a discussion
on it I don't I didn't know this uh
Georgia is a little bit different can
you tell us I'm pretty sure I mean in
fact but I think George has a panel the
governor has to has to confer with a
panel for apartments okay yeah different
states I think Florida the governor can
just pardon you but Georgia yeah might
be with every State's different what if
another State Board of Pardons and
paroles there you go what if like uh
DeSantis won could he part of him too
uh yes the Santa said he would pardon um
Trump if he became president yeah
important or he would he would entertain
it yeah he would entertain it I will say
something just totally none like totally
irrelevant it was funny that you said
nook and cranny because I thought for a
second I'm like what's a cranny
no one ever says that word unless they
say nook and cranny yeah and so I looked
it up cranny is a very small narrow
space Oh it's kind of obvious what the
hell is a Nook then also a small
it got me thinking about waffles yeah
the commercial is like they're pouring
the maple syrup and they're like
covering every nuke and cream yeah I
mean so I think the the most the the the
the charges I'm most concerned uh uh
concerned with are the document charges
because they're pretty cut and dry he
had them they're at the house they're
classified or National Defense
information
um they gave them a chance they're gonna
argue we gave them months we you know we
had to open up a grand jury
investigation to get these documents we
did a search warrant we look at all of
these ridiculous acts we have to take to
get these documents back that's what
they're going to say the um the January
6th stuff I mean Jacksonville has a hard
on for Trump at this point to be honest
with you but the thing that worries me
as well is that I know how the feds
operate right and just for the audience
to understand the feds have the luxury
of taking the cases they know that they
can win and the cases that they want
most U.S attorney's offices have a 90
plus success rate with their cases yeah
like the southern district of New York
it's such these big districts they don't
lose because it's the DA's offices that
typically lose because they take on
disorderly charged disorderly conduct
they take all the dumb charges but the
feds take the big sexy cases so
typically they don't indict
with until I remember when I used to go
and present for grand jury et cetera
because I would go in there and present
you don't indict unless you know you're
going to win the trial yeah you you
indict ready to go to trial at that
point I remember going with It's a grand
jury with all my stuff and then we would
hand the discovery over to the defense
Council everything there and they were
like oh man we're gonna need some time
to review this and then sometimes the
overwhelming amount of evidence makes
them say we're just gonna plead yeah so
then what happens if Trump is convicted
of of which one that anyone the document
one yeah
we'll start there because that's like
what's what's the what's the what's the
penalty
they're going to label them a spy is
what they're gonna even though that's
ridiculous and ludicrous they're gonna
say oh he was he was convicted under the
same charges that we go after spies with
Robert Hansen
um operation um Shadows which I know
they caught those 10 Russians that were
here spying for like a damn near decade
and then we caught them what did we do
we traded them for you know some other
spies because that's what we do so
they're gonna go ahead and try to label
him as a spy unfortunately which is
ridiculous and it's a lot of these
charges if if I'm not much mistaken like
these are the type of things that they
would always give the benefit of the
doubt to a past president for because in
the political system if you were in the
inside you were given leeway and they
weren't going to go after you and that's
the part that bums me out is because you
see a lot of people who feel like
they're getting this guy and that he's
always been this evil figure not
realizing that this is the he's doing
the same stuff that Obama did the same
stuff that bush did the same stuff that
bush senior did that Clinton did all
these things are not new to the system
it's just that this dude needs to be
taken down because he pushed from
outside the establishment I want to say
this too as well if you if you look
right anyone that applies or anyone
that's watching that has a clearance
that works for the government you guys
know some of the questions ask you have
you ever tried to overthrow the United
States government
um have you ever you know collected
information for foreign government Etc
the two charges they're getting them for
it on the federal side are what one is
an Espionage side that they can label
them a spy and the other one is
overthrowing the US government what do
both these charges have they disqualify
you from the government service or they
label you as unfit for government
service and that's what they're trying
to do but
if Donald Trump in any way is removed
from this election
bedlam yeah
I just ABS absolute chaos it's going to
be chaos yeah they better not remove it
I think for this they shouldn't remove
them if Trump gets removed from even a
single state I think social ordinance in
this country ceases to exist yeah but
people need to understand this I do
mention this a lot but you know in the
context
I'm in Egypt during the revolution you
could still go to McDonald's and order a
cheeseburger you could still go and and
buy Goods at the mall you can still buy
a cell phone social order breaking down
and the government collapsing doesn't
change the fact that people are still
living and trading and working in
business that are running so by social
order breakdown I just mean
like I said you're gonna get uh the
other day you're going to get people in
small towns
who will just look at a guy with a
federal badge like a guy in a clown
costume like no different a guy with a
clown and a clown who walks up to you
and says hey don't move and holds a
rubber a rubber nose in front of you
freeze you're like
what is this what does that rubber nose
mean to me get out of your clown hmm
there's gonna be people in small towns
who are going to see a Fed hold a
federal badge and be like you might as
well hold up a clown now does that mean
anything to me yeah no I mean it sucks
because you know you go from like let's
let's look at the FBI you go from an
agency that you know was responsible for
putting away people like La Costa Nostra
invest investigating some of the most
egregious crimes against the United
States and you know now their images
tarnished right all the good that
they've done right they've done a lot of
bad too but they don't care because yeah
they're being weaponized right to go
after U.S president they're they're
they're they're they're in on it now I'm
not saying every single FBI agent
because I've actually I've spoken so
this is the thing like a lot of people
are like abolish the Intel agencies
I don't completely disagree uh splinto
the CIA scattered to the wind all that
stuff we all know those statements Vivek
wants to abolish the FBI what he really
means is transfer them to various
different agencies they'll never be able
to do that unfortunately and I like
vivec too I've met guys who work in
Intel
and I asked them yo what's going on and
they say everything you see outside is
exactly what's happening inside you ever
wonder why it is that like
man what what example could I think
outside my head people won't speak up
about some issue they'll say oh like
leave me out of it I'm scared the
average person women uh trans trans
women in female sports like obviously if
you ask the average person the polls
show most people do not want this yeah
ask them publicly with a camera in front
of their face and they shut their mouth
and they say nothing yep so that's what
that's what I'm told by some of these
Intel guys they're like a lot of people
here voted for Trump a lot of people
don't like what's going on but they're
scared if they speak up they're gonna
get fired they're gonna get shunned
they're gonna osterize they're gonna get
targeted so they just keep their mouths
shut right yeah I'll tell you from my
experience
um when I was on a job a lot of us were
supported Trump trump was pro-law
enforcement you know what I mean when he
was in so the law enforce of community
loved them it's the guys at the higher
up because here's the thing too I want
people to understand
you got a special agent right that guy
is a gs13 right whatever he's doing his
cases he's doing what he's got to do
it's the management the 14s the 15s the
sacks um you know the directors etc
those are the guys that are making the
political moves Etc trying to move on up
the guys on the ground that are doing
the cases a lot of the times man they
just want to do their cases be done go
after the bad guys you know it is what
it is but it's the guy it's the brass
that are doing this crap that where a
lot of times is politically motivated
but yeah a lot of a lot of guys a lot of
um law enforcement guys especially at
the lower levels right they're Pro Trump
they're they're Pro because those guys
are pro law enforcement but here's what
they do
some higher up guy who's political
finds people he can trust to agree with
him and then says they're putting me in
charge of insert Bureau in office
I want you to come work with me we're
gonna do X Y and Z so then you end up
with a particular office where
the guy running it is politically
charged he brought a bunch of his
buddies who are also for political and
now you have this one particular office
where everybody is doing taking part
partisan action
so these agents that are investigating
and going after Trump they like that
they're doing it they're not upset that
they're doing it well it's DC agents so
to so and I'll clarify that too so DC is
super woke we all know this right
um it was actually the the DC office
that ran that investigation and when
they came down they did the search
warrants they did everything and you
know the obviously the Miami Field
office is going to help and everything
else like that but it's the DC office
that's running it so you know it is what
it is man
um
it's just a sad time in America but oh
go ahead you made a very good point
earlier about how other presidents in
the past did the same thing that he
basically did but they got nothing for
it and uh it's scary because you look at
it from a holistic standpoint Trump is
basically advocate for like the opposite
of what's currently in political space
however challenging anything that's
currently like setting Stone here for
the political uh landscape is demonized
and it means that any of the president
tries to I want to say do the opposite
is going to be shun too so it's kind of
scary bro and you look at I mean look at
uh there's there's lots of pictures of
bush with Obama they're they're all
friends right it's it's now about Good
Old establishment versus populists and
people to support did you see his
interview with Tucker yeah he said in
there that basically everything started
to roll once he got rid of Comey oh wow
yeah he said in the interview with
Tucker um you know you like basically
they kind of started the Pitchfork
started to come out once he got rid of
Comey and what you how you described
what was going on what whether we're
talking somebody high up in the in the
government who then hires people that he
knows are loyal to him that's why I take
a lot of issue with the idea of during
the swamp they're like get rid of the
heads of this agency get rid of this
agency like all of these people mentored
people who even if they're not
necessarily 100 in line with them as far
as their political views they feel a
sense of loyalty to that person or at
least the the person who's in charge is
politically Savvy enough to hire people
that he knows think the same as him
right because he's training them to if
not succeed him to work under him to
help him achieve whatever he wants to
accomplish right it's not easy it's not
so easy as to just fire a bunch of
people because somebody else is going to
take that job and you run the risk that
that person is going to be every bit as
bad as the guy you fired once once
you're at the what we call the special
agent in charge level which you know
some age some agencies call it Sac or
saic or Etc it starts to get political
and that's the guy that's the head of
the field office right of a of a certain
you know geographic area and they're
overseeing you know sometimes hundreds
of Agents so yeah at that point starts
to become political and they're really
just kind of the the you know the
puppets of the higher ups over out of
the Washington DC office
it says here on uh uscodehouse.gov
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned not more than 10 years or
both
not more than 10 years what are the
chances he gets convicted and they just
say all right you were found guilty time
served time served I was in the Bible of
which church specifically the Espionage
oh the Espionage one the chance of him
they just say no fine time served have a
nice day disqualified yeah
they don't need to put them in jail
that's the thing like the fear is that
Trump gets put into jail which causes
Bedlam everyone's like ah screaming but
they could just be like don't worry
we're not gonna lock you up we don't
think you're a threat Beyond this
because you're not president and your
penalty is that you can't run for office
anymore I'm using that even worse though
then it then it looks to the people that
I know that just dislike him and don't
understand how politically motivated
this is that screams politically
motivated to just say yeah no no they'll
have to throw them to make it seem like
there was actually a crime for them to
punish him for if they just let him go
then it absolutely looks like a banana I
think the strategy is this and I think
is I'd said this on the on the onset
when he first got indicted um and I
think his legal team is trying to do
this delay delay delay man he's got to
make it to 2024 win the election pardon
himself from the chart the federal
charges and um hopefully you know the
state of Georgia can we can figure
something out with that but you know and
then the New York stuff I'm not even
worried about that's that's the best the
Georgia stuff is where the cast ensues
because if they do convict him
and he gets sentenced to jail and then
he wins the presidency
what happens when they're not going to
trial though on that for years dude the
state of Georgia is so backed up these
State courses kind of Chase world is
going October 23rd for the for the
retail charges that's right October 23rd
of next year no
October 23rd this year impossible thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time